as night fell Hong Kong's pro-democracy
protests showed no sign of ebbing
despite the government's ultimatum but
the demonstrators are divided on what to
do next some say they intend to stay put
in the busy shopping district of Mong
Kok while others fearful of a crackdown
by the authorities are calling for
protestors to leave the area it's
because we're worried about the
potential for more violence bloodshed
and ongoing confrontations we are all so
eager for Mong Kok residents and small
businesses here to get back the room
they need to breathe during the day
there were occasional scuffles as the
tension mounted but these protests have
remained largely peaceful despite anger
from some local companies that business
has been brought to a standstill Hong
Kong chief executive CY Lyon called for
an end to the demonstrations the police
have threatened to act if they continue
police have deep responsibility and we
are determined to take all necessary
actions to restore the Public Order
protest leaders have called on the
demonstrators to clear certain areas
they have agreed to remove some barriers
and they say the demonstration should
leave Mong Kok and concentrate on the
government quarter of admiralty so far
threats have failed to move the
protesters it's unclear how the
authorities will react